nédélec berriac bonsoir alors encore une
fois que retenir bien évidemment de
cette conférence de presse d'olivier
ferrand et de jean castex soir
la vaccination nous protège et protège
les autres a déclaré ce soir jean castex
le premier ministre celui là même qui a
déclaré à la télévision il ya quelques
mois que deux doses de vaccin eh bien on
pêchait la contamination et la
transmission du virus il avait tort
visiblement l'objectif actuel avec le
projet de loi du pass vaccinale et ce
sont les mots du premier ministre et de
faire peser la contrainte sur les
non-vaccinés eux qui sont les premiers
malades ducobu 19 hospitalisé selon ses
dires
dans tous les services de soins
critiques l'immense majorité des
personnes hospitalisées avec des formes
graves de l'aco vide ne sont pas
vaccinés ou n'ont pas de couverture
vaccinale complète j'ai parcourir la
france des services de réanimation pour
dire elle a sa ble ment au personnel mon
soutien et mon admiration et je peux
vous dire qu'il n'ya pas photo sur la
nature des hospitalisations et des
formes graves ce sont des personnes non
vaccinées ou des malades vacciner mais
atteint de comorbidités graves
l'élément que les décisif est et demeure
la vaccination voilà pourquoi comme je
voulais dit lors de ma précédente
intervention nous faisons tout pour
accélérer et renforcer la vaccination
le délai pour la dose de rappel qui a
été réduite de 6 à 5 mois en décembre à
2 nous veaux étaient réduits il faudra
compter trois mois désormais entre les
différentes dose de rappel conformément
à l'avis de la haute autorité de santé
les principales mesures annoncées ce
soir par jean castex l'écran un
rassemblement sont limitées a plu à 2000
personnes en intérieur à 5000 à
l'extérieur
la consommation des boissons et de
nourriture dans les cinémas théâtres et
enceintes sportives sont interdites pour
les trois prochaines semaines le recours
au télétravail est rendue obligatoire
dans toutes les entreprises dans la
mesure du possible avec trois jours de
télétravail au minimum pas de couvre-feu
pour le 31 décembre comme hypothèse a
été posé sur la table hier et bien la
mesure n'a pas été retenue le premier
ministre a toutefois appelé les français
à la plus grande vigilance à continuer à
maintenir les gestes barrières et si
possible porter le masque pas de retour
pas de report non plus de la rentrée
scolaire les écoles seront bel et bien
ouverte à partir de lundi prochain ce
qui concerne les nouvelles règles disent
elles manquent à contacter pour les
personnes qu'à contacter tout cas
positifs elle devrait être annoncé d'ici
la fin de la semaine mais on devrait
revenir logiquement à une durée
d'isolement de sept jours comme c'était
le cas avec les précédents et variant et
plus de 17 jours comme c'est le cas
actuellement avec le variant au micro
d'olivier veyrat qui était aux côtés du
premier ministre ce soir appelé les
français à se faire vacciner en masse
pour éviter les formes graves de la
maladie même si le variant omicron est
nettement moins dangereux que les
variants un précédent l'écoutent
omicron a cette capacité rare contaminé
des personnes qui ont déjà attrapé le
coc vide et même des personnes qui ont
eu des formes symptomatiques voir des
formes symptomatiques cder du coc vide
cette proportion a contaminé change
aussi la donne on peut donc retomber
malade si on attrape le au micro mikron
est moins sensible aux vaccins que le
variant delta mais c'est une bonne
nouvelle la troisième dose quand on
était à jour de son rappel fait
immédiatement remonter le niveau de
protection au dessus de 90 % même bien
au-dessus de 90 % face au risque de
formes graves
les personnes à risque restent donc les
personnes non vaccinées les personnes
vaccinées mais qui sont très fragiles
parce qu'elles sont très âgés ou parce
qu'elles souffrent d'immunodépression et
puis les personnes qui ont un schéma
vaccinal qui n'est pas complet
c'est-à-dire les personnes qui ont eu
deux doses mais pas encore leur
troisième une vaccination complète
éloigne le risque de formes graves
éloigne le risque de réanimation même si
vous deviez contracté le virus
une nouvelle évaluation de la situation
devrait avoir lieu la semaine prochaine
puisque un nouveau conseil de défense
est prévu ce sera le 5 janvier prochain